I hope that your wife gets harassed more
at work, okay? Holy
She's like totally psyched that people
are doxing Dan's family.
That's crazy. By the way, I think this
might be the one line. This may be the
one line that Destiny might go, "Oh,
actually you got to go."
I'm not joking. Oh, he called me a
Yeah, of course I don't want to feel bad
for him anymore. Yeah, or for his wife,
or for his kids. What the First of all,
I hope they get harassed more.
Yeah, I hope I hope he gets doxxed, I
hope he gets swatted. Yeah, I don't care
anymore.
Like maybe they're only on Kick or
something, but this is totally
termination worthy. This is crazy to
openly call for swatting somebody and
not just them, but their family and
kids. Dox and swat them. That's crazy.
>> He went there. Yeah, of course.
Okay.
So, Food Slops and Dan are fighting?
Apparently.
So, this started a couple days ago when
Dan Was it Dan? I think Dan made some
comments about Food Slops being a Or Mr.
Mouton made some comments about her
being a pe
So, this is her, I think, getting mad
about the mods in the DGG Discord.
Let's see. Let's see if that's what this
is.
>> Okay. All right. Oh, also, there's
There's something that's gay and
and I
hate it. It's stupid, okay?
I think I think they deserve to be put
on blast, all right? Just mainly because
So, I'm back in the DGG server, right? I
I'm back there.
I'm climbing, okay? Chilling, all right?
Not instigating any drama, not doing
anything crazy, all right?
I have no idea why,
but Okay, so the clip that I posted
Okay, so the clip that I posted, okay? I
Okay, I hope that when I say I hope that
when I say um that
the rest of DGG really hates me, that's
the truth, okay? The rest of DGG
actually actively hates me. They hate my
ass, okay? So, I posted this and I
wasn't even thinking a
All right. Okay. She basically did
Listen, she wants She aspires to be
Destiny in all ways, okay? I believe she
sent photos of herself uh like nudes to
somebody underage. I believe there's
logs of this. I believe Aiden's gone
through those logs.
Right? Am I crazy? I'm not making that
up, right? I'm pretty sure I saw this.
Mau or Aiden should know about it.
Um Now, lucky for Food Slops, it
actually doesn't matter how much Food
Slops attacks other people around
Destiny. Destiny needs her to exist to
keep the very dumb members of his
audience occupied and to keep believing
lies. You need somebody who like has no
concept of the truth, has no concept of
understanding people's arguments, right?
He needs that person to exist. So, he'll
always support Food Slops. Doesn't
matter how many times she calls Dan a
or whatever the else goes on, right?
It'll never matter. He'll always support
Food Slops. So, she's lucky there.
Okay. A useful idiot, the very
definition of such.
So, she's lucky there. No matter what
she does here, she's fine. She'll always
get covered, okay?
But, attacking Dan, not good with the
community, okay? Maybe a little bit
better. Maybe if Dan Since Dan walked
away from the podcast, maybe it'll be
thought to be a little bit better.
Possibly. Possibly. Okay, so she The
core part of this clip is that she got
mad at a Discord moderator, okay? Um
Apparently, it's the same vod, possibly,
but Mouton calling her a
as well.
And I'm sorry. I I can't I can't with
that, okay? I I
I just can't do it, okay? Or should I
say Daniel, all right?
Danny boy and Mr.
Mouton, okay? See, this is what I mean
by
This is dire. I
This person is like actually having a
fight with Dan. They're actually going
to like burn a bunch of bridges. It
should be good content,
but they're so unbearable to watch
that's What are we going to do? What are
we going to do?
>> people going after me,
okay? Like this is what I mean by people
going after me for no reason, all right?
For Dan,
I think Dan is the only exception, where
Dan has not gone after me personally,
but I am going after Dan
just simply because
I feel like I have a justified reason to
do so, okay?
That's fair, okay? Dan has every reason
to be mad at me for going after me. I'm
not going to complain about that.
I don't think Dan wants to be associated
with either. It's why he got so mad
about the Diddy stuff, right? Dan really
doesn't want to be associated with
at all. So, this person like mentioning
them, watching podcast clips, he's just
like, "Ugh, leave."
Which is understandable. Everyone gets
it.
>> Okay, because I hate Dan, all right?
Now, with that being said, with that
being said, okay?
What the did I do to Oh.
By the way, Dan paid me to do this
segment, just so you know, okay?
Uh Dan gave up many shackles, okay?
Behind
Behind closed doors deal, okay? He paid
me to do this, to go and go through all
of Food Slops' stuff, so We got to do We
got to do this.
>> Mr. Mouton, I'm sorry. Does Mr. Mouton
and Dan share a single brain cell?
Like you guys are like squabbling over
like how the Fates squabble over like
the single eyeball. Here, let me just
play this.
Z's probably going to win, and that's
okay. Who Z?
>> No. No, that would be ally of the year
or something. That is not um buddy.
[laughter] So, uh
I've heard that Food Slops is
unironically a pe
Dan's going to go, "I don't know even
know who that is. I don't know what
you're talking about. Let's move on."
Dan Dan doesn't even want to engage. Dan
is so disgusted by
He'll be like, "No, let the do whatever
they want. Just don't mention them. I
don't want them around me."
>> going to say any
What the [__]
Hello? Dude, it's crazy. It's crazy up
in this I just got put up in
by like Mr. Mouton, what the I
I never get why people pretend that like
there's just no way you could understand
how someone would think that with the
clips that this person has out there. I
just I don't get it.
>> here, um but
I before I had no issue I I'm not I'm
not going to say anything
here. Yeah, of course. Like it's crazy
to me how Dan is more submissive than
Mr. Mouton.
>> Holy [__] Holy [__]
Mau is like uh Mau is like Mau is
producing the whole segment. Mau just
sent me like a whole list of a trillion
things here.
Jesus Christ.
>> Okay, but Mr. Mouton is like dumb enough
to say something like that. Oh my god,
it's like Beavis and Butt-Head, dude.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, do you have the big spoon
compilation of her being record in VC
with DGG mods? I don't know what that
is. Just load it up. We'll go through it
right now.
All right. Let's load it up.
>> want to see this whole thing-ish a
little bit, right?
>> It's fine. So stupid.
Z's probably going to win, and that's
okay. Who? I I just I'm just curious
about the whole context. No, that would
be ally of the year or something
something. Oh, also, I'm going to I'm
going to say that because Food Slops
consented to showing all of the things
that Mau just sent me on stream
that I'm going to infer implied consent
here, okay? I'm going to go ahead I'm
going to be a big man here and I'm going
to infer that it by through implication,
because she au- authorized Mau to show
it on stream, I also have consent to
show it on stream.
>> That is not um buddy. [laughter]
So, uh
I've heard that Food Slops is
unironically a pe
What Ooh.
Oh.
Let's go. Turns out that's He's still
thinks you're going to bro. Anyway, it
it doesn't really matter. Like dude, bro
Steven's orbit, dude. And I'm going to
every single time Steven comes in here
or I talk to Steven, I'm just going to
say it again and again. It doesn't
really matter if he never joins in here
again or never talks to me again. Dude,
[__] DGG, dude. DGG is a bro. DGG is a
It's so crazy. Like it's so crazy to me
What What did she think was going to
happen? How um DGG
like
Destiny will never never let you go,
okay? Destiny's going to keep He's going
to keep you around. It's fine. He'll
He'll keep joining your stream.
>> Destiny
is admirable because he's able to have a
lot of nuance, and he's very careful
about allegations, and very careful
about how to label people, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Um he only would argue for things when
he's like sure beyond the shadow of a
doubt. That's where he got the review
segments from. But nobody from DGG
None of that is true. That is obviously
just straight-up a lie.
Uh famously accused by community in
Discord of doxing with no no proof
whatsoever, propagated that out to his
audience, who also says that same thing.
Just no proof whatsoever. Obviously just
a straight-up liar. It's just not true.
>> learns this skill from from Destiny.
Nobody, except for me, I guess. I'm the
only one. Uh like except for Che Logic
and other people who derive from like
Just a total lie right here, again.
>> Uh Destiny as content creators. Like
nobody
Once Destiny's case ends, Food Slops is
getting dumped. No, probably not. learns
this skill. Everyone is just crazy up in
this Anyway, the point is it's not like
dude, DGG just sucks, okay? No wonder
you guys can't get your content cre-
like career like things going because
you guys just like I don't know. Like
you guys are smoking some crack, okay?
Anyway.
Aha.
>> Like
Okay, I
I'm sorry. I By the way, I never went
after Mr. Mouton, okay? I never went
after him.
>> Never in a million years have I went
after Mr. Mouton, okay? Please, just
pick up one clip where I said anything
bad about Mr. Mouton outside of calling
him cringe, okay? Which everybody says.
Cringe is not the same as
What the You were
attracted to drawn depictions of kids.
All of your your all of your dynamics
are about what about kids, about being
childlike.
I'm sorry. You You will never escape
this. With the with the quotes you have,
with the things you've described, you
will never escape this reputation. This
is your reputation forever.
Hello? [clears throat] Anyway, um yeah.
Good
>> [laughter]
>> Good stuff, okay?
All right.
All right, I'm going to play this one.
Let's see, what is this one? Give me a
second.
This is This is the big one, okay? This
is her talking about Dan the other day.
Wait, do I go to this yet? Thank you. I
love you guys. All right, that was all.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
She's just watching Destiny's stream?
Nice.
I don't want to say FoodShop's is wrong.
About what?
>> Well, they're
so that's kind of expected.
Oh
[__]
Hold on. Rile, is this too far ahead or
is this about where we are?
What are the leaks before this or after
this?
Hold on.
Wait, is it Why is Dery still in here?
>> [singing]
>> And that's why I criticize his
parenting, okay? I thought you were
supposed to do that. I thought it was
really unhinged to criticize other
people's kids and their parenting.
That's why I think it's a reasonable
escalation, okay? That's why I think
it's a reasonable escalation, okay?
I hope that your wife gets harassed more
at work, okay? Holy [__]
Okay.
Oh, and now she's like totally psyched
that people are doxxing Dan's family.
That's crazy.
Uh this person's going to die. Like not
literally, but figuratively, okay?
Um
Listen, there's a reason I've never once
Every time somebody says something about
Dan Dan's family, I'm like, "Nope. Nope.
Don't do that. That's crazy. Never do
that. That's psychotic. It's internet
[__] Don't bring kids into internet
shit."
Okay, don't bring people's spouses into
internet [__] Apparently, she's just
immediately Dan called her a and she's
just like, "Yep. Yep. This guy deserves
to be doxxed and harassed and his family
deserves to be doxxed and harassed."
Immediately. Bro, seriously.
What?
indefinite Oh, I By the way, I think
this might be the one line.
This may be the one line that Destiny
might go, "Oh, actually you got to go."
I'm not joking. Oh, is Dery still in
here?
He's been Yeah, he's been in here.
You [__] god. Good for him. My boy.
Probably got arrested again.
Okay, probably in some girl's room
again. Okay, I hear that's been
happening. Yeah?
It's right here.
Just remember, every single battle I
pick is justified, okay? Just want to
just in case anyone wonders if I'm being
unhinged.
What part of them calling you a means
you should go, "Oh, actually it's cool
that your wife's getting doxxed and
harassed at work."
I don't I don't know, man.
I don't know.
Wait, so are Dan and Destiny back
together now? Dan's never broken off
with Destiny's ever is distance in any
real way. That's crazy to think he did.
All right, well, I love you guys and uh
stay safe, be careful.
All right, see you, man.
Jesus.
Was Dan even aware of this one, by the
way?
I'd like to think Dan's somewhere out
there right now watching the stream. I
wonder if he was even aware of this that
this person actually said that he
deserved
to have his wife doxxed and stalked.
That's crazy. Harassed at work, eh?
Well, what can you do? Haters going to
hate, okay?
They hate us cuz they ain't us. True.
Holy [__] Which is
Bro, he called me a
Yeah, of course I don't want to feel bad
for him anymore. Yeah, or for his wife,
or for his kids. What the Of course not.
I hope they get harassed more.
Is this DUDE, IS THIS
>> [laughter]
>> THAT'S TOTALLY INSANE TO SAY, OKAY?
OBVIOUSLY, that's insane to say.
It's totally [__] nuts, but
I will say
totally on brand. Totally on brand. This
is kind of um
Jesus Christ. Why would you do this?
See you later, Kiriko. This person has
every single thing going their way
with regards to they get free
viewership. All they have to do is be
Destiny's like use like useful tool.
That's all they have to do. And they
decide to go after Dan and say
say the one thing that Destiny says is
the worst thing in the world, harassing
people around the the creator you're
beefing with. That's like the evil
thing. And she's like, "Oh, yeah, I love
that your kids and wife are getting
harassed."
Why?
I Maybe it's made up. Maybe it's kayfabe
or something. Maybe this is a thing
they're doing intentionally. Who knows?
That makes This makes no sense to me.
They're They're turning inwards and
calling for the doxx of the orbit. I
mean, I know I couldn't get away with
that, right? I could never get away with
something like that.
Oh my god, could you imagine the
FoodShop stream if I said, "Oh my god,
Dan deserves this."
Holy [__]
Yeah, I hope he I hope he gets doxxed. I
hope he gets swatted. Yeah, I don't care
anymore.
Oh,
okay.
>> [laughter]
>> I keep I keep pausing and going, "Oh,
that's really crazy to say." And why
would you ever
Okay. Okay. Okay. [laughter] Okay. What
the [__] What the [__] is happening?
How did I How did we not know about
this? Was this today? My one, when was
this? This is [__] insane.
No, he totally disavowed this,
obviously. No, was this today?
My one, when was this stream from?
I actually don't know and now I'm 2 days
ago.
Bro, how does nobody what Nobody caught
this?
It's been 2 days. They said this 2 days
ago and nobody caught this. What the
[__]
That's crazy.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right.
Cool.
Um
I think that afterwards um
Uh actually, hold on. I need a
Listen, just a real quick, you know, a
real quick heads-up. I just want to make
sure that Mr. Saltman is aware of this.
1 second.
We do We do a little reporting. Little
reporting.
Are you aware that FoodShop's ups was
advocating for doxxing and swatting you
and your family on their stream
recently? Question mark.
I We should We should inform Dan. I
think that afterwards um
he opens the Zip Zip stream. Why does he
call you a Why would he care about that?
Uh because he's
Well, why would he care about that?
Well,
there's a little thing that most people
do. It's like, "Don't do the thing to me
that I do to other people." I don't
know. I'm trying to think of a
principle. We call it the the copper
rule, okay? Don't do to me what I do to
other people.
Although, to be clear, Dan's never
swatted anybody. I don't know why she
just called for swatting Dan's family.
Seems kind of odd.
>> Uh
It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter
whether or not he called me, right? It
like to me it doesn't matter. It could
be either from the anti-fan videos, it
could be either from rumors, it could be
either from Mr. Mouton, or he's just
saying that because he likes calling
everyone Dude, there's somebody We need
the meme, okay?
FoodShop's talking about her like
anti-fans and her biggest anti-fan is
actually FoodShop's.
Putting all of that crazy [__] about
their therapy and treatment for it on
tape.
>> You know, it does it doesn't matter. It
doesn't
Like Like once you go there, I'm just
I'm just going to do tit for tat. Like
at that point, I'm just going to do tit
for tat, right? By the way, this is
She's unironically just living her
principles the whole time, right? If you
believe that having that talking about
things that happen on the internet If
you If like basically if if I'm aware of
some fact and it's also posted to Kiwi
Farms and then I stream and that fact is
on my stream, apparently that's enough
reason to try to doxx me. This is like
the same thing, right? It's basically
like I get to go as hard on you as
possible the second I think you're
snarking me at all. This is like the the
kind of principles they've been living
out in the world.
It's natural that this would happen.
Now, of course, this is not how anybody
else actually wants to live. It's just a
totally made-up like tiny sphere here
where Destiny is using these ideas or
the fact that these like these
would-be principles, these would-be
standards, they're using them just to
attack people who are on the other side
of his legal cases. That's the only
reason they exist. They're not actually
standards anybody follows.
Right? And FoodShop's about to realize
that, I think.
Um yeah.
There There's no reason for me to like
hold back anymore at that point, yeah.
CounterPoints does that as well, yeah.
And I And I also criticize him and his
family.
I do that, too. Because he
Oh, yeah, this is so amazing. I'm still
sitting here as the guy who doesn't do
any of this, by the way.
I don't I don't do any of this. This is
But them, they they go do all of it,
right?
I I think it's like unironically
I don't even want to say I I'm
Yeah.
Like this is the kind of [__] you just
get bumped off of you You would get if
they didn't edit their YouTube vid, they
would get auto bumped off of YouTube for
this.
This is like actual termination worthy.
Actually termination worthy.
Like maybe they're only on Kick or
something, but this is totally
termination worthy. This is crazy. To
openly call for swatting somebody and
not just them, but their family and
kids. Dox and swat them. That's crazy.
He went there. Yeah, of course.
Yeah, of course I'm not going to
Um actually, I said I just wouldn't feel
bad if it happened and they should it
should happen.
Okay. Good one. kid in my dialogue, too,
for their feelings at some point, okay?
Of course not. What the [__] And And by
the way, even then even then, I still
like
I still compliment CounterPoints despite
that. It's like so crazy to me. Okay,
well I don't have their whole vod here,
but um
damn, that's that was that would way
harder than I expected it to go. What
the [__]
Jesus. Okay, I need to keep going
through these. 1 second. What is the
next one?
Let me see.
Uh day after food shops began to really
lash out at Dan and the DGG Olympics
also continued to devolve.
I I don't know what this is. Apparently
there's DGG Olympics things going on
right now. Let's see.
What is this?
>> Something more at stake for um in terms
of Dan, all right, than
>> [snorts]
>> than money. Oh, this wasn't Mrou this
was My Waifu actually. Hold on.
Oh, is this vod on Kick by the way? If
this vod's on Kick I we could find
timestamps too.
>> Okay, what's money? Dan has plenty of
that, right?
You know what Dan really wants?
Dan really wants his manhood back, okay?
I think he's going through a erectile
dysfunction, okay?
Hear me out, all right? The amount of
aggression
that is used to compensate for all of
that insecurity
over very small issues is projection,
okay? He feels like his manhood has been
taken away. He's unable to pleasure his
wife in the bedroom.
All right, I understand.
Don't worry, okay?
Don't worry, we know you're aging, okay?
I've heard that like some of the most
unhinged things. The unhinged stuff that
happens on Kiwi Farms is the
psychoanalysis. I thought psychoanalysis
was really bad. It was really unhinged
anti-fan behavior.
This kind of psychoanalysis is supposed
to be unhinged. I thought that was the
bad thing, guys. I thought Kiwi Farms
was evil and doing this was quote
unquote unhinged. No?
No?
Okay.
>> It's getting harder and harder or should
I say softer and softer.
>> imagine that this would have been Okay,
hold on. We got one last clip here. It's
been a 10-year running thing for me.
You you said
>> discr- I've been very specific about the
exact timeline of events as I'm
understanding Let's go back in the vod
and hear what you said. Yes. Let's go
back to the vod.
>> minutes because because before your
stream on anything else, before your
some- something else or any I don't
remember which one.
I do want to know why Dan's a
Well, because he calls me a So
therefore, you know, depending on how
much other people bring up my past
dramas, you know, I think it's all
projection, okay?
I think it's all projection. It's as
simple as that. Right, before that
Here you I I
Ah.
It just feels so good to be vindicated
in every way.
Person has no principles, incapable of
analyzing any facts,
incapable of analyzing reality in any
way. Very very funny.
>> what he done
posting it, right? And then
>> what everyone and 100 people on anything
else pulling it up as well.
And still only six viewers.
No, there was like a half hour.
>> 50 people had answered the poll.
Uh we can actually let's go to the vod
and see at what point we started talking
about it and then at what point
uh
we get that
>> I don't know what you're arguing with me
on this for. I can't believe Dan called
me a
over this. He called me a
over a a poll over Celeste being the
option.
Dude, are you
Or somebody just told him that you're
actually a
Could easily be that, no? You actually
kidding me, dude? That's all I'm saying.
To fighting with no principles? Well,
this is true watching you back.
Uh unfortunately for Food Slops, okay?
Dan has the facts on his side on this
one. Very unlucky.
Very very very unlucky. She tries
reaching out to Dan, she tweets about it
and then she's removed from the Daliban
Discord group.
So she goes to Twitter com today, posts
this. Tried to de-escalate one step with
Dan and since he declined I've no reason
not to post it on Twitter anymore in
public or in the community group.
Putting it in here
putting it here in public helps also
helps archiving since he loves redacting
things.
Hey yo, listen.
I'm not okay with you calling me a
on stream. We're going to have our
massive disagreements and we're going to
beef, that's fine. However, using
Steven's platform to call me a is
another step up from trolling you I'm
not okay with. I'm sending this because
a friend said I should try direct
communication and I agree. I think it's
better to resolve this in DMs even if
you do it as a joke, it obviously still
propagates it.
If you agree to stop calling me a PDF as
Dan, then I will stop calling you a
child response and I won't engage in tit
for tat and just dude, all these people
say tit for tat. This is like
slowly becoming
a Destinyism and maybe it already is.
And just criticize her ego
interactions, which is a step down from
PDF jacketing.
Do we have a truce?
Dan responds, "Never mention my name
again and I won't talk about you again.
Going random rants about me and around
and find out." Haha.
Haha. Okay, okay. Um damn.
I whatever, I don't know if this seems
to be This is way different than the
response Dan's the responses Dan gave
me, but
Oh well. Dan, I sorry, just in general I
feel like Dan would actually talk to me
like a human being.
He must know more about Food Slops than
we assumed.
Anyway, Dan, I criticize you for your
ego and you think calling me a is okay.
I didn't see any ego criticisms there,
but okay.
Then fine, no truce. I think I made the
step to make peace and people can't say
I haven't tried now. This is not a
reasonable compromise to me considering
how my entire streaming is talking about
Destiny related figures and drama and my
honest opinion on them. I am sorry, it
is what it is. No, your your entire
streaming thing is is
literally just lying.
It's literally just you you hit play,
somebody says something, you don't
engage with it at all and you go, "This
person's an idiot."
Can't can't explain why, can't really
follow it, you just say it.
That's your thing. You're Destiny's
useful idiot.
Okay, related figures and drama and my
honest opinion on them. I am sorry, it
is what it is. I but I but I guess a
truce is impossible. Have a good day.
Oh, I actually have these in further
down in the album, don't I? This is the
last one. Dan responds with a thumbs up.
That's the whole
four. And then he deleted his messages
instantly. Logged them before he could,
thankfully. That's it.
Does this make her look good?
Why would she post this?
I I actually don't know why she would
post this. So she posted this to the
Daliban, okay?
Posted this to the Daliban and then
Let's see here.
Then then
they got banned from the DGG Twitter
community, okay?
So the response from DGG from I guess
Ekroth's bath probably was just "You've
been removed from this community.
Moderator removed you for violating this
community rule, respect Destiny and
stream guests. Your post in the
community will be hidden and you won't
be able to join again."
Doom.
So I guess I don't know I don't know,
man. That seems that seems pretty
brutal.
She's done all of this lying for you
guys and you're just ready to throw her
away?
That's [__] up.
What did you do? Went after another DGG
orbiter in in the Daliban community
against the rules. I'm assuming this is
the case. Either way I accept. Okay.
My boy? No, not my boy. Okay, since I
got banned from the DGG community
reposting them on my own account. Here
is my IVP ceasefire being rejected real
time. So I feel no obligation to keep it
courteous since my effort to de-escalate
happened.
Hey, you should stop calling me Stop
calling me a
Uh no. Okay, well that I tried to make
peace.
Okay, I
All right.
Sounds good.
Dan then goes to my server and starts
talking about it, which is kind of
funny. Wait, why is she watching me? And
then he's going to cover that. Maybe
he'll get to it, maybe he won't get to
it. Okay, who the [__] knows? All right,
it doesn't really matter, all right? All
you need to know is that it seems as
though from
Oh, I put it in the title, that's why.
Yeah, I am going to cover it. Yeah, and
then we're probably going to do a bunch
of the stuff. No, no, no, I didn't do
any of that yet, Mrou.
I
We're just covering the drama with her
and Dan.
For some reason she called for Dan's
family to be talked to and swatted. I
don't know why. She's like, "Oh, I I
hope that happens to them."
>> Maybe he'll cover me, maybe he won't.
He's not he'll cover me versus Dan
Saltman. Okay, fine. This is no
accident. So
you know how Dan is supposed to be a
defender of Destiny against all the
anti-fans?
>> [laughter]
>> Wait, I got to know where this is going.
She's going to she's basically going to
go, "Remember all the work we've done
explaining how Jstark's community is
evil?
Well, guess where Dan went and
complained about it." It's where he
went. Honestly, I didn't even know I I
decided to cover this before I even knew
Dan posted it on my Discord today.
I I wasn't watching, unfortunately.
So I'm being told and I have received
screenshots of Dan on Jstark's server
trying to incite
against me and
even though he never talks there
he went on to Jstark's
>> just so you know, Food Slops, Dan paid
me to cover this segment, okay?
Undisclosed Ethereum payments.
Guy used to mine a lot of crypto, okay?
You'll never be able to find the money,
but he did pay me.
I'm I'm not going to not going to cap,
okay?
I figure Jstark's server, anti-fan
communities
in order to complain about me, okay?
So we have the friend of Destiny
fraternizing with the enemy, okay? Uh if
you're in DGG, let's say you're watching
this. Maybe you're watching Food Slops
watch this.
If you if you found that that statement
right there compelling, I loser, you
will never do anything tangible in the
world. Please kill yourself and give
back some of that oxygen and ozone
you're taking up, okay? Thank you.
>> So that's what's happening, okay? Do you
think Dan is on the other side? I think
that somehow because he's so spiteful
that he has decided it would be a great
idea to
complain about me on J Stalk's server.
Okay, yes, it's as crazy as it sounds.
Okay.
So,
this person's name Hassan, but make no
mistake, this is Dan. I I believe that
Wait, replay it? Oh, she said something
about fraternizing with
>> So, that's what's happening.
And
even though he never talks there,
he went on to J Stalk's server anti-fan
communities
in order to complain about me. Okay?
So, we have the friend of Destiny Oh,
right here. Yeah. fraternizing with the
enemy. Okay?
Fraternizing with the enemy.
The enemy.
Cool. Uh so,
yeah, if you find that compelling,
you're a loser. There's no enemies here.
Um any of you people are welcome to come
and argue but where I was wrong with any
of my coverage of the Destiny stuff.
Food Chops too scared to do it. You're
all too scared to do it. So, you sit in
your community probably have to
get there being total degenerates.
I really can't think of any better hell.
I can't do anything worse to you than
you've already done to yourselves, okay?
>> So, that's what's happening. Okay? Do
you think Dan is on the other side? I
think that somehow because he's so
spiteful that he has decided it would be
a great idea to
complain about me on J
This is the one thing me and Destiny is
unique in his community, okay?
He's good with He likes
But most of the other people around him
and me, we can all come together against
you and Destiny in our disgust at Okay,
we are we are disgusted by you guys. We
will always just, you know, I will make
content out of you. I will make a
mockery of you for being a
whenever I want, whenever I can, okay?
And Dan will enjoy it. Dan will take
part in it. Dan might join and talk [__]
about you. Probably not, to be honest,
but
We all hate
We all do. And you are one.
>> Okay, yes, it's as crazy as it sounds.
Okay?
So,
this person's name Hassan, but make no
mistake, this is Dan. I I believe that
multiple people have told me that this
is Dan. Yes, it is Dan. The person with
the so-called Hassan account, okay?
So, um you'll notice that the tag, the
server tag right here is redact or
redact.dev, okay? Obviously, the real
Hassan would never have anything like
that as a server tag. That'd be crazy if
so, right?
Um so, I'm being told
I mean, wouldn't it be crazier if the
real Hassan was in my Discord dropping
Food Chops tweets?
Wouldn't that be way more crazy than Dan
this being Dan?
Guys, this isn't the real I know you
think this is the real Hassan, but it's
actually just Dan Saltman.
No, it'd be way more insane if Hassan
was stalking on Food Chops in my Discord
server, okay?
>> This is the real Dan, okay? Obviously,
you can prove me wrong. Please, please,
please tell me if I'm getting any facts
wrong. Again, I am trying to I'm trying
my hardest, okay, to get all the facts
correct and in order, okay, from
beginning to end, okay? All right.
So,
Dan, not Hassan, says, "Oh, no." So, he
posts this, shares this in J Stalk's
server.
Does Destiny know this? Dan is running
to J Stalk's server?
Dan's never left my server. I never took
Dan's perms away. Dan could join right
now.
Dan doesn't leave servers. Dan By the
way, Dan sat out the whole thing in
spicy chat, like participating the whole
time when Destiny was trying to like
totally disingenuously frame what DK was
saying about him.
Basically trying to totally smear those
people, too.
>> of all things, J Stalk's server
like my public callout. Okay, fine.
Okay, you want to do that? You want to
incite some real
Oh, hold on. J Stalk, did you see they
got kicked out of their house because
they refused to stop yelling during
stream? Nope. Oh, wait. Yeah, I did. And
requested her fans to move in with one
of them and that Oh, yeah, I know. We
covered that. It was very sad. Yeah, we
covered that. It was very sad.
For sure.
Yeah, I know. When she was basically
like putting it out there, like, "Can
one of you guys help? I just I can't
find a roommate who will help me through
my search." me. Okay, you did that. You
You're feeding
my my like my enemies, my direct enemy
and enemies of Steven. By the way, these
are enemies of Steven most of all.
They're not They're not like immediately
enemies of me. Like obviously, by
extension, they are direct enemies of
me, but like primarily, their target is
Steven, right? Like let's be honest.
Like taking down me, like if they take
me down, that's only a step in truly
taking down Steven, right? Does that
make sense?
We're just going to I'm just going to
cover this and show why
you lie, why Dan is correct in calling
you or at least like not remotely wrong.
Right? The The only argument she'll have
is that like technically she'll
basically just be able to say
technically she hasn't actually
a child. Just a non Best case scenario,
not offending
Like I hope that makes sense, right?
Like again, their primary target is not
me. They're
I believe that the only reason they
stopped talking about the stuff on the
internet. They did talk about it. The
only reason they stopped talking about
it is cuz they know you can't have a
career on the internet while openly
expressing attraction to kill kids.
Yeah, children. Children. Chil-
Children, kids, whatever. Okay? That's
why they changed their story on it.
That's the only reason.
primary target is Steven, okay? So, we
have a long time friend of Steven's
going to J
to post this Like, okay, dude. So, so he
shares it here, okay, because he's like
feeling full of it, all right? So, the
Just in case again, in case Food Chops
watching this, your audience is watching
it. Um Food Chops doesn't actually have
a point here, right? If this was all
fake, if there was no meat on the bone
in terms of people calling her a
wouldn't she be like psyched about this?
Wouldn't she just be like, "Oh, this is
awesome. Dan's totally up here."
Also, why is Dan posting this? Do you
think I wasn't aware of this before Dan
posted in my server? I didn't become
aware of it through Dan. I got I was
aware of it through people DMing it to
me, people who aren't in my server.
Okay?
Like that's not what made me aware of
this at all. I decided to cover it
before I had seen anything from Dan.
So, Dan posted it, but he actually is
blameless here.
Dan didn't put me on to this. I was just
going to cover this anyway.
Realistically, he shouldn't have posted
it. Would have had the same outcome
whether or not he posted it.
But now I'm sure I'm just going to go
through all of the stuff all at once.
And you know what?
The other thing is is we do that we do
this. Listen,
we do this gratis. We move the timer.
That timer That timer don't exist
anymore, okay? That timer don't exist.
We got a lot of time to spend to just go
through. We'll make sure we understand,
all right? And guess what? If I get to
the end of this and you haven't claimed
to jerk off to drawn depictions of kids
and you haven't claimed that you've had
attractions thoughts about kids, if you
haven't claimed attraction to the idea
of manipulating younger kids like like
actual children into relationships, if
any of those things are wrong, I will
say so at the end of this stream, okay?
I will say so. But I'm guessing listen,
it's possible that everybody's lied to
me. It's possible that every single
person who's ever told me to cover this
stuff before and then I was like, "Uh
that person's kind of gross. I don't
want to." It's possible they all lied to
me and it's all made up and we'll find
that out and then I'll go, "Oh, you know
what? Food Chops was right the whole
time."
But obviously, I wouldn't be doing this
if I thought that was going to happen.
Oh god. Dude, this is like this is like
you realize how childish this is, right?
Oh, true. True. Hold on.
Right. Quick outfit change. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. This one?
Nope, not this one. Wait, this would be
if we're going after Dan. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on.
This one. This one. This is the one.
We're not going after Dan today. We're
going after Food Chops.
Right. One second.
>> Like you'll realize like why I feel like
a 26-year-old parent. Like Like Like
this guy Just keep in mind, this guy is
like in his 40s, okay? Like this guy is
like a parent.
He's a parent with a full family. Like a
full-fledged family and multiple Like
Bro,
I Okay, listen.
This is true, but that's always been
true. Also, can you think of somebody
else who's a parent who spends all of
their time involved in childish drama?
Is that really Is that really the line
you want to go down? Wait, if you're a
parent, you shouldn't be engaged in
pointless internet internet drama
mongering. Is that Is that your
argument, Food Chops?
Is that
Is that what you're saying? Hmm.
It's almost like all of your criticisms
apply to somebody else you're supposed
to be on the same side as. To be very
frank, okay, to be extremely frank,
to be extremely frank, okay? You need to
grow the [__] up, okay? Seriously, okay?
How is it that I'm more mature than you?
It's insane, okay? It's insane.
Uh she's more mature than Dan, the
self-made billionaire
who has a family, has a wife, has kids,
okay? Obviously, doesn't spend a ton of
time with them. They must be mad boring.
But that's beyond the That's beyond our
conversation currently, okay? But
he's got all of that and she is begging
viewers to be able to move in with them
so they could take care of her after her
transition surgery.
And Dan is the one who has to grow up.
Now,
I don't even know that I disagree Dan
should grow up a little bit, but let's
be real, okay?
At least he's grown up. At least he's
moved past his his childlike phase,
okay? He's not putting childlike
graphics up on the screen. He's not
acting like a kid. He's not
kids. At least he acts like an adult in
most ways.
>> It's insane that I have to deal with
like actual men children. Like what the
[__] Hello? Like what is this like high
school
What's with this stupid gossip girl high
school [__] Anyway,
so
So, we have Oh, Dan just joined the
battle. So, this is confirmation. This
is confirmation from like one of the
anti-fans, right? That Oh, yeah, Dan
just joined the battle. So, if you have
Th- This person wasn't even in my This
person was in Loder Boxes' community
when this whole thing started, by the
way.
They're like a new addition to the
community. Any like doubts if you have
One of Loder Boxes' mods, in fact, I
believe.
>> about this not being Dan? Um yeah, just
if you have doubts about me, just make
sure
I'm just
Is that incorrect, my one? I don't think
that's incorrect, right? Unless I'm
totally misunderstanding who you are.
Saying, okay, this is this does actually
seem to be Dan, okay. This anti-fan just
said Dan just joined the battle, okay.
So, this is a screenshot, I think, and I
don't know if Zip Zip is there, but
this is like
this is Dan saying, "Zip Zip?" So, this
is again, this is in Jstark's server, it
seems like, right?
"Zip Zip sounds the exact same as Jstark
in cadence, and I don't give a [__] if
anyone thinks I'm right."
So,
let's be clear here, okay?
I don't know if that's true.
I don't see why I think that sounds like
old me, like when I first started
streaming.
Right? When I didn't have any inflection
in my voice whatsoever.
>> Yes, this is an insult towards Jstark,
right? Because again, he's implying that
Jstark sounds horrible, which is
absolutely correct, right? However,
remember that
That's like your opinion, man.
It's subjective.
>> insult, right? Because he's insulting
Jstark, right? Making fun of him, and
he's insulting Zip Zip, right? So, he's
roasting Zip Zip at the And by the way,
I have a suspicion that this happened
right after
Is that Why does she make like stupid,
petty insults like this that are just
like ribbing between people that doesn't
matter? Why does she try to make it
sound like it's immoral?
Oh my god, she's she's he's insulting
Zip Zip and Jstark, okay. She's she
He's insulting both. He's insulting
both. Oh my god.
Did Dan do this?
Dude, who cares? Listen, I don't give a
I don't care. I literally don't care.
>> After the debate between Zip Zip and Dan
about the Celestin the same topic, the
Celestin.
Oh, did Zip Zip and Dan had a Did they
have a debate about food jobs?
Hello? Anyway, it's just kind of funny
how Dan just molds he molds after every
interaction. He molds after every
debate. Do I go on to anti-fan Discord
servers to complain about my ops in DGG?
What?
Why does she think that this is anything
to do with Dan?
Like, it's just funny that you have lost
it entirely. You called for a huge You
said you thought it was justified that
his family were doxxed and swatted or if
they'd be doxxed and swatted, you
thought it would be justified.
That's crazy, man. That's crazy.
>> do that
as a 26-year-old? Hello?
You know, I'm constantly thinking to
myself, "How do I be the most mature?"
No shot she just said that. I'm
constantly thinking to myself, "How I be
the most mature?" As I sit in this like
child-coded Discord, have these child
this fantasies about children, as I only
play video games all day, that's my
entire stream is just me playing video
games and not understanding or following
anything
following anything
in the videos I watch.
Dude, this is the most childlike,
immature existence that could possibly
happen.
All funded because you're willing to be
Destiny's like chief propagandist.
You're willing to just lie about the
things that other people say.
Sad. Sad existence, my friend.
>> the most chill? This is not it, okay?
I'm just saying, okay, anyway.
So,
there you go. There's a Zip Zip mention,
I guess, like also insulting Zip Zip.
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> So, Dan then says, "My perfect online
reputation." Okay, so this is sarcastic,
I'm assuming, like whatever. So, this my
person says,
who is a dedicated anti-fan, okay, for
right now. Who will win Destiny's
handmaiden role? You must do battle with
Food Cops and Zip Zip. Okay, I just I I
think this is gay, okay? I I don't give
a So, this person
Dan's flirting with the idea of going
back to Destiny, and Destiny would love
if he could have Dan around because as
much as some people hate Dan, at least
he is like somewhat intelligent, at
least he is somewhat competent.
Holy [__] Destiny being surrounded by
like Food Cops and Zip Zip at all times,
he must He's in a hell of his own
making, okay? He would trade you guys in
for Dan in a heartbeat, instantly,
overnight. He would just be in and out.
You guys get the [__] out of here, Dan's
back. He does anything else. Oh my god,
it'd be like there'd be some normalcy
returning to his life. Okay? Now, I just
I love that Food Cops doesn't realize
she's getting swapped out. She doesn't
see it. I don't
>> [clears throat]
>> I don't think Destiny will do it yet,
but
it will happen the second that If the
case gets dropped, if the case gets
decided on, you out, Dan's in.
>> this? A laughing emoji, right? So, it's
people who are going like, "Okay, wait,
hold on. Is Dan coming around to our
side?"
It's time to say
We don't want Dan on our side.
We don't I don't So many people in DGG
don't get this. WE DON'T LIKE DOXXERS.
WE DON'T LIKE DOXXING. THAT'S NOT OUR
THING. THAT'S YOUR THING. We don't want
Dan back. We don't want doxxers around.
Except in Discord for times like this,
okay? Except when they they come in uh
and participate and get to make
themselves fodder for my drama for my
stream. But other than that, no, we
don't want doxxers around. into the
anti-fan side. Like that's that's how I
read it at the very least, okay?
So, Dan then says, "I would be 10 times
more concerned if Wolfgang came at me.
This person has no influence and is a
known
This is again, all right, again me,
okay? So, if you guys don't don't know,
this is like the
the fence registry like pin, the red pin
that is on the fence registry maps, and
basically this is the red pin. He's
doing a red pin emote because he's
basically saying, "Oh, yeah, I'm a
person on this fender's registry." No,
he's calling you
It's like just a colloquial way of
saying
calling you a He's not saying you're on
the sex offender registry. He's saying
in a justified world, in a just world,
okay, not justified, but just world,
you would be on a sex offender registry.
Basically, he's trying to like Alas, we
live in this world.
>> matter. Okay, so
and then and then Dan says like a
weird comment like a
I don't know why he said whatever, man.
You know, his sense of humor is his
sense of humor, right?
How is this person still around? I don't
know, but I'm enjoying, okay?
I do think it's very funny.
You can always count on this with the
DGG people as well. Like you you do know
that this will happen. Like they will
turn on somebody like this almost
immediately.
Uh this happened By the way,
uh Food Cops, you got to push through
it, okay? Just push through it. They
turned on me, didn't work. Didn't work.
Even when I'm out of the orbit, didn't
work.
Dan will Listen, if you if you can win
this, Dan will just start coming on your
stream. He'll admit he'll he'll just
admit defeat. He'll start coming on your
stream, okay? You can do it. Just push
through it. Keep Keep advocating for his
wife and children to be harmed, and I
know you can win this, okay? Just
kidding, don't do that. Obviously,
disavow that. But
I'm sure you come up with a better
tactic, okay? Uh you can win. I promise,
you can win. So, he compares me and Zip
Zip to Wolfgang, okay? I I don't know
all that much about Wolfgang. I don't
have I have no beef or quarrel with him.
He disappeared from the Jstark sphere a
long time ago. Anyway, at least Wolfgang
has a hot mom. Um okay.
Uh you're not referring to the same
person. The Wolfgang guy is not around.
You You don't know who you're referring
to.
>> All right, I I don't know if your wife
is okay with with you saying that. By
the way, normally when someone says,
"Oh, yeah," like makes your mom jokes,
normally it's because it's like it's so
absurd that there's no way it can be
true, but like I would probably wager
that Wolfgang's mom and Dan's age is
probably around the same. I don't know.
Like obviously, don't look too much into
it, but
like
Like I don't know
This is obviously half joking, right?
Like this is obviously half joking,
right? But
okay, you know, do your thinking, all
right?
Anyway,
the Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. The hot mom
thing with Wolfgang is that Wolfgang and
Dan used to hang out a long time ago,
like more than a decade ago, and for
some reason they got Wolfgang to post a
picture of his mom, and Dan said his mom
was hot.
That's the That's the whole joke there.
Um
Let me see. Weird.
Okay. Let me see. Dan brought Wolfgang
to the So, this is Jstark
finding [laughter] out that Dan
Dude, this scared Dan away so fast.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey Dan, be careful posting in here.
There's someone online threatening to
dox anyone in this channel. I think Dan
left at this point.
So, Dan says,
"You said that feeling when and didn't
do a face."
Okay, so this is referring to some other
conversation, I'm assuming, whatever.
So, then uh
Jstark says,
"Uh and he has talked about Wolfgang's
hot mom on other occasions." Really?
Okay, sus, okay, whatever. Okay, Jstark
says to Dan, "Be careful posting in
here. There's someone online threatening
to dox everyone who does." So, this is
talking about Destiny, okay? This is
talking about Destiny, all right? So, um
because Destiny says, "Oh, yeah, if
you're in Jstark's community, I'm going
to go around doxxing everybody in
Jstark's community who are like the main
stays, right?" Because
No, he just basically made it totally
open-ended, threatened to dox Wicked
Supreme, who's done nothing remotely
worthy of doxxing, okay?
Literally nothing. Destiny has no reason
that he would threaten to dox Wicked
Supreme. Insane to do. Obviously, an
insane thing to do. Um but he's not
acting like a sane, irrational person.
He's totally obsessed with hating on
this community. Crazy.
>> Like I don't give a [__] anymore. I'm
just going to collect all your doxxes
and just punish you all, right? Oh,
Short Fat Otaku says I'm a conservative.
I am not. I'm not a conservative, not a
populist anymore. That was cured very
quickly by this Donald Trump fellow.
>> collective punishment. So,
again, um this is Jstark also poking
poking fun at Steven, but also poking
fun at Dan, um and and yeah, saying
like, "Oh, yeah, you're one of us now,
right? Like you're you're in here with
us, so be careful." That's basically
what
I literally said, "Get out of here, man.
You don't want any part of this, buddy."
YEAH, GET OUT OF HERE, DUDE. YOU DON'T
WANT NO PART OF THIS.
This is what I'm saying.
>> sound pointed towards Dan, in my
opinion. Just I don't I don't know. Like
I don't I don't see any real animosity
between Dan and these anti-fans. All
right? I I don't know if there is, okay?
I'm being told that Dan does regularly
go into Jidion's community to go argue
with them.
I have to say, okay, you
I don't think so. I think if you at Dan
and you say something mean to him, he'll
usually respond and tell you to [__]
off.
>> Must be doing a really bad job.
I'll put it that way.
>> They just laugh at you all the time,
okay? Dan Okay, Dan. All right, listen.
Okay, if you're jealous of me being like
the one true
No, Dan is like Despite Dan being like a
totally unprincipled crazy doxxing
lunatic, a lot of people still like him,
actually.
>> absolute Destiny defender, okay? It's
okay, okay? You're not cut out for
everything in life, okay? That's
probably why you failed like 10
different businesses, sold off all of
them, probably, and you'll work for us
two bigger companies, and now Redact out
Dev is like your baby, so then you have
to like grab a hold of it of as you as
much as you can, because your previous
10 companies are all like aborted
fetuses that you like ate for dinner or
some [__] Okay, fine. All right, you
want to do your thing, that's fine.
Um you Excuse me, you only have like $40
million. You're
like really You're like barely a
millionaire, okay? You're like barely a
millionaire. You suck.
But listen, not everybody is cut out for
everything, okay? It is what it is, all
right?
So
you know, there's all these like red
flags going off, okay? Like
Like Okay, I can totally acknowledge Dan
being spiteful and doing crazy Okay, but
I
did not imagine that Dan would go to
Jidion's server. How is that like a
crazy thing?
It's very embarrassing to have this
opinion.
By the way, that e-rape defense squad
channel or whatever, um we had a whole
bunch of like like Pisco community
members who were in there who left
because of the doxxing threats.
But they would just like argue the other
side of the case, and then we just have
like good discussions on it. It was
totally normal back and forth. Nobody
was like threatening anyone.
It It was literally just a back and
forth over and over again.
I don't know I don't know where this
reputation comes from that it's like
some crazy Well, sorry, I do know. It's
disingenuous lying scum like this person
and Destiny. But
it's just like a normal back and forth,
man. There's nothing crazy going on. Two
Two
to validate the anti-fans crusade or
some [__] So, again, if you're
watching, you probably won't watch
because I'm going to keep pausing here,
but there is no crusade. Um like Dan
wouldn't even be validating it if he had
a problem with food shops and attacked
food shops. That wouldn't validate any
criticism that I would have of Destiny,
right? She's just trying to get She's
trying to use my community as a wedge,
right? She's taking the thing that
you've already had defined for you by
Destiny by food shops is evil, my
community, and she's trying to use that
as a wedge to say, "Oh, Dan participates
there. He has to be evil as well." She's
just webbing, right? Just webbing Dan
in.
You don't have to You don't have to use
You don't have to listen to that. You
don't have to pay attention to that. Dan
is who he is. Dan is the same as he's
always been. The entire time Destiny was
fighting with Chud Logic's community,
Chud Logic's editor, Dan was in spicy
chat the whole time, was still friends
with Chud Logic, right? It's the exact
same exact same thing, except Dan and I
aren't even friends. He just hangs out
cuz he likes being in places to read
stuff.
Okay?
So, you don't have to hate Dan. And I
was going to cover this whether or not
Dan posted it at all. Anyway, but we're
also You should stick around if you were
watching this to watch, you know, food
shops' reaction to this.
You should stick around, or you should
go to kick.com/Jidion, watch this VOD,
cuz we are going to go through all of
the actual
factual evidence of food shops being a
that she herself has provided for us.
All right? So, stick around if you if
you want to, and we'll go through all of
that stuff. Sure, it'll be educational.
What the
What's up, Ico? Food shops is So, food
shops and Dan are fighting. Dan called
food shops
Food shops said she thought it was
justified that Dan's family was being
doxxed and his wife was being harassed
at her workplace, and she also, I
believe, said it would be whatever
happens to them is justified, including
doxxing, swatting.
So, it might have The language might
have been I don't even feel I wouldn't
even feel bad if they were doxxed or
swatted.
So, very cool, very neat, very very
awesome. Yes.
I mean, I guess he's his own person. I
guess he's his own adult. But do you
know what that means when
adults do things?
I think that adults choosing bad
decisions like that should have
consequences.
I think that should have consequences,
in my opinion.
All right? In my opinion.
Okay? Because if you have the mentality
of a child, okay? Like Dan does.
And you're very spite-driven, okay?
Which I understand.
All I'm going to say is
if you want me to regard you as an
adult, you must take responsibility for
your actions, okay? I take adult
consequences for my adult actions, all
right? Now it's time for you to take
yours.
Where's the responsibility? I mean, be
honest about why people call you a
Don't pretend it's like some video game.
Although this is a Could be a video
game, almost certainly.
Don't pretend that's the only thing
going on here. Oh, hello.
Who's this? Dickers with 13 viewers.
What's up, Dickers crew?
What up? What up? What up?
We're covering the fight, okay? Between
food shops and Dan Saltman.
Many Many allegations of
thrown back and forth. Of course, we
know the ones against food shops are
valid.
And we're We're going to cover some of
that stuff. We're going to check that
out. We're going to see what's going on.
>> opinion, if I had absolute control you
give off so many red flags that I would
oust you instantly.
Mods
twist his balls, you know? Send you Like
if I had absolute control, I would kick
you out of DGG permanently.
Okay? I would say, "You're allowed to be
my friend, but I'm going to kick you out
permanently, okay?" I'm not going to put
that pressure on Steven, okay?
But I'm just saying Does she feel any
embarrassment saying this?
Like she She knows that they're friends
in real life, right? And that Dan stood
with Destiny through like the toughest
part of those allegations.
That would like everybody else walked
off, Dan stuck around.
I I don't think she actually I don't
think she actually understands, okay?
There's something going on there. I
believe I I this I could not advise
against this any more strongly. It's
very stupid to to take in here, okay?
You are problematic, okay? You are bad
news, okay?
Um and I think that all the I think that
all the DGGers who um were fighting
against
Oh, that's a good point, actually. We
should sprinkle in some of the
the PDF file clips. Hold on a second.
Oh, hold on. Actually, she did send her
DMs to Destiny as well. I'll check those
out in just a second. But somebody gives
a good suggestion. We should cover some
of the allegation stuff while we go
through everything. So let's look at
some of food shops' DMs with a known
seven a known minor at the time, okay? I
believe this person was 17.
Let's see.
It's It's these DMs, okay? 2024, this
Ico person, apparently 17. I didn't know
this, but apparently, okay?
Oh, no, Ico, we can go over that one,
too. I'll give that a second, okay? We
do have that clip.
But this is them talking to a
17-year-old. No, how do you stand to
watch so many commentators when all they
do is make fun of degenerate gooners
that are targeting you? To be fair, they
are gooners, too. Lyrics. True, Lyrics
is a gooner. Well, yeah, Chud talks
about gawk every 5 seconds. LOL.
I can't believe this cute IRL loli
Japanese girl is in this space who is
actually into me. This is why I think
I'm being catfished. The chances can't
be possible. Well, let's see. No
evidence of your identity or existence,
but that's okay. I guess the pictures
can be AI-generated. Hmm. So, I don't
know anything about this person other
than I've been told this person like
tries to
flag people. What's up? Who is this?
Hey.
>> this person? To be clear, so food shops
doesn't get you in a little a little
gotcha, they told food shops
>> think this person
Yeah, I don't think this person has
advertised that they're overage. Or
sorry, underage.
Yeah, they told food shops they were 18.
I think the biggest issue here is that
when food shops figured out that they
were lying about their age, they didn't
ban them.
I believe the screenshots in or are in
order, but that at one point they're
asking food shops like why
why am I like banned from your server?
And they're like, "Oh, you're 17." So,
they figured out they were a minor, and
then
kept, you know, correspondence with them
and all that [__] But yeah, food shops
did not message this person
thinking that they were 17. However,
this is like insanely reckless because
they were sent one picture of this
person's chin.
>> Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Oh god. Can I just ask what you
think cute IRL loli Japanese girl means?
Um so, food shops, I believe Ah, god,
it's it's been months since I covered
this. Food shops, I think, said that
this person would send them like audio
clips or something. I don't know. They
did like a loli roleplay. They did like
loli roleplay with each other where they
would and pretend to be like lolis and
underage and [__]
Cool.
>> Hi. I would like to point out something,
just, you know, to be fair, to be
transparent. Hi, Mrail. Um Hi. Mrail has
a crush on food shops.
I have a crush on the idealized version
of food shops. I don't think food shops
is very hot.
>> hot. So No. To be fair, No, you're
misremembering things. I think food
shops has the potential
>> be hot. She could be hot. Yeah, you're
looking at her thinking
>> to get there, but she's not there yet.
Yeah, yeah. I think she's far too lazy
to ever get there, so I don't think it
would ever work out.
Okay, but, you know, there's there's a
twinge. There's a twinge somewhere in
your body. Uh
I think it's I think they're fairly
repulsive right now. It's like, um you
know when you see like a homeless like
homeless like Down syndrome girl in New
York. How do you look at them and you're
like
Sorry?
>> ask, how are you like still talking
normally as if something normal just got
said? You have a You have like a gun
right next to [clears throat] you, don't
you?
>> [laughter]
>> Uh where is it? Oh no, I moved it. I
moved it cuz I was sitting up my ear.
Do you hear that? Can my mic pick that
up? I don't know if my mic can pick
>> I didn't I just I had a intrusive
thought. Go ahead. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, I
think I think there are pictures of food
shops where they like brush their hair,
they you know, take nice pictures, they
try to look nice. But um I I don't think
that's often. And I think if they really
tried, they could look attractive, but
their hair is like greasy, they don't
shower, they don't brush their hair,
they don't brush their teeth, they don't
try to look good. There's like a clip of
them on stream where they're actively
like with their their contacts and it's
just very repulsive behavior. But I
think um I think they have the
potential, you know? I think they It's a
missed opportunity, more or less. Where
were you going with the homeless Down
Syndrome
situation? Oh yeah, I Okay, back to
that. If you're in like New York and you
see like a homeless Down Syndrome girl
like on in in Times Square or something,
you're probably not going to look at
that and be like, oh I'd want to hit
that. But you'd probably look at that
and be like, oh that's a missed
opportunity. Like she's in the Big
Apple, she has, you know, every
opportunity in front of her, she she the
sky's the limit, she could look good,
she could look beautiful, she could look
amazing, but she's not, you know, she's
homeless in Times Square like with a
foam cup that she's begging for money
with. It's It's missed opportunity.
Like in the same way that like like
could be hot to you? The homeless person
in New York could be hot to me? I think
like I like I said, I think
>> Syndrome. Down Syndrome
Down Syndrome was more so a a
metaphorical
you know, term to express how dysgenic
and freakish this homeless girl looked.
I don't think they would actually be
Down Syndrome. It's more so to convey
how bad they look in this, you know,
instance of them being homeless.
Okay, so not mentally. It's also, you
know, like when you see like a fat guy,
I'm sure you see this, right? Do you
ever go to the gym You go to the
climbing gym, right?
Not these days, but I Do you ever go to
the gym or go out for walks or something
and you see like a fat loser and you
kind of look at it and you're like, you
know, maybe if he if he, you know,
exercised and you know, put a little
effort into his outfits and into his
swag and maybe, you know, got a haircut,
combed his hair a certain way, he'd
probably, you know, look more f-
Is that Is that him being totally
swagged out?
I don't to- I don't think about it in
that sense, but like, you know, there's
something
>> what I'm getting at, Charlotte? Yes, in
a in a less disgusting
>> guy put more work into his appearance,
he would probably look a bit better.
Yeah, that's typically how how it works.
That's what I see with Food Shops cuz I
feel like they're not even doing the
bare minimum.
I feel like they're extremely greasy,
not well-kempt at all, and it's it's
almost annoying because they get decent
money from streaming, unless they stop
getting donos, I don't know. But like
they they have enough money to like get
decent shampoo, get soaps, you know, get
a comb, brush their hair,
you know?
So it's more frustrating that they don't
put more effort into their appearance,
especially if you're going to cam. If
you don't want to put effort into your
appearance, why do you think I'm not
cammed up? I haven't showered in a week.
But nobody knows that because I'm not
showing my face on a camera, you know?
The moment I turn on my camera, I have
to start taking care of how I look. I
have to start, you know, combing my
hair, I have to start brushing, I have
to start cleaning myself, all right?
Mhm. But they're not doing that. They're
basically me if I just turned on the
camera, but didn't change my behavior at
all, which is very disgusting, I think.
If they If If you Like Like Jstock, if
you started camming up, I would expect
you to like maintain yourself, look
decent. If you cammed up and you look
like a dysgenic freak, I'd probably be
slightly disappointed and I I I would
expect you to feel the same about me. If
I cammed up and I just looked like a
freak, I'm greasy with like unclean
clothes and sh- you know? Does that make
sense? Yeah, I know what you mean, yeah.
Yeah, got it. That's what I'm getting
at.
Yeah. Okay.
Um
So there was that There was the one
other aspect that I was going to bring
up. Oh, also, you you talked to
17-year-olds, too. So what do you What
do you Why are you even commenting on
this part?
Uh because I didn't want Jstock to cover
the segment thinking that they knowingly
messaged a 17-year-old.
Okay.
>> Oh, I didn't think that, by the way.
I I remember you saying something like,
this is a known minor that they
messaged. So I got the impression that
you
>> we know we know at this point I All I
know about them is I think they joined
my server and somebody messaged me like
like an hour or two after they joined my
server and was like, hey, did you see
you know, this person like catfishes
people?
Yeah, I I I might have misunderstood
what you said. I just wanted to make it
clear like, hey, this person did not
intentionally message a 17-year-old.
Um cuz I feel like
>> For some reason you misunderstood what
happened, this could be a pretty big L
on your part. So no, I'm My My point
here is not Also, I think Food Shops is
like 26 when they did this. So I think
it might be a bit different. A
26-year-old messaging a 20- 17-year-old
than a 21-year-old messaging a
17-year-old. So even if I did have an
issue with this, which I don't really, I
don't really care about a 17-year-old
adult. But even if I did have an issue
with this, I also don't think there
would be like anything wrong with that.
Yeah, I think there's something weird
and wrong about pretending to be little
kids and doing that, yeah. Yeah, I just
think I think in general it's like
degenerate
>> two consenting adults, I don't really
care. But yeah, the pro- fact that this
person at least catfished Food Shop like
I don't I feel I feel like the bare
minimum you can do is like
know what they look like.
>> also engaging in like engaging in age
play while having all of the quotes that
this person has and [__] is also just
very weird, right? Well, they have those
quotes because they engage in age play,
right? Well,
no, the quotes I
Hold on, hold on. Wait, wait, wait,
wait. Hold on, no, no, no, no, no.
Actually, I take that all back. Sorry, I
need to just get this thought out. No,
not knowing not knowing that you can't
put those quotes on the internet, not
knowing that those are like
like totally That is the terrifying
thing. Putting all of her statements
about like
children on the internet So what Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. What are you
saying?
>> socially degenerate that is, that's that
is the problem.
So am I just not allowed to be like
racist on stream anymore?
Why?
What do you Where does that come from?
Food Shops said something about lolly
and now they can't age play in DMs. Am I
Am I just not allowed to like make
racist jokes about black women on stream
anymore? Like is that the standard we're
using?
You're in the You're in the States,
aren't you? She's just allowed to be
racist.
Um I don't think
>> think Food Shops is allowed to lolly
roleplay with consenting adults. Yeah.
Being racist is
illegal.
>> all of it ending up in public is the
issue, right? The fact that she would
openly understand Oh, that they
willingly made it public. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And they're not joking.
>> It's not a joke. They're not out of
context quotes. Like she actually means
it when she says I see.
I see. I see. I I misunderstood. I
misunderstood. I thought you were saying
that if you have a
degeneracy that you can't then
I understand. I understand. Okay. I
understand. I misunderstood. Okay.
Cool. Okay.
Yeah.
All right, cool.
>> Yeah.
Bye.
All right, see you.
Oh boy, it seems we don't have the Resi
videos of her talking about her therapy
and [__] That's somewhere, right?
That's got to be somewhere. I know there
was like a Kiersch video about this a
while back.
There's got to be Queenen coverage of
this. Where's this [__] at?
Someone tell me where this [__] is,
okay? Call Resi? I don't need to call
Resi right now. I just want the videos.
Listen, I've We'll find them eventually.
>> Hold on, who's the Who's the trans girl
that doesn't voice train? Food Shops?
No, no. They're like really tall, they
live in the woods now, they don't make
content anymore.
I'm I'm blanking on the name. I do know
who you're talking about. Not a Not a
clue.
They They don't Hold on. Is my wife
allowed to be here?
Not DemonMama. They covered Food They
made a documentary on Food Shops and
like talked to psycholo- Zonia. Zonia.
Zonia. Zonia. I was going to say Zonia.
Okay, bye. Yeah, yeah, Zonia. Zonia has
a Food Shops documentary. I don't know
if it's still public, it's unlisted. If
you go to their channel Actually, I'll
see if I can find it for you. I'll DM it
to you if I can't find it. I mean, you
just want to DM it. Zonia Zonia has a
documentary, talks about all this.
Yeah, sure. Diggers just sent me two
clips as well. Diggers just sent me two
clips as well.
Yeah, all right, I'll send you a video.
All right. So anyway, these screenshots
were Let's just look. This is the first
one
that's posted. All day you're probably
like, I wonder what Food Shops thinks of
me. I wish I could read Food Shops'
mind. Stop it, anxiety brain, that's
you.
Wow.
Sorry, I had these out of order before.
I just wanted to read them in order,
okay?
There's this one. Well, I mean, I'm into
that anyhow. Wait, that's your
controversy? Yeah, I said I openly
consume on a stream one time and
everybody freaked out.
Uh no, you said other things as well.
This is not the only thing she said.
There's more lying, more more lying.
Lots of people say this, and while they
do get called
there's a lot less concern than there
was with Food Shops in the first place.
Okay.
All right, we continue. We continue.
Where are we going? This one next. Okay,
no, wait. How do you stand to watch so
many commentators to be read this one?
Talk about Lyrics Chud.
I can't believe this cute IRL lolly
Japanese girl is in this space who's
actually into me. Ha.
I think this person like does some kind
of like catfishing [__] I have no
[__] idea.
That's what I was told. Okay, next next
picture.
How did you do it? How did you generate
this? Which AI did you use? This is very
convincing. Can't reverse image search,
can't find the source. I mean, there's
no way anybody with this
with No way somebody with this good skin
is talking to me or this alt cute.
I'm not really I'm totally a magic girl
NPC. I'm a figment of your imagination.
I'm literally in your mind. We need to
think that's the case, Mrs. Chat GPT.
Ugh, no more. Wait, this is the Roblox
one. I don't know what this is.
Not even reacting to mine. Why do I have
Roblox MP4s? Okay.
Lord, I have multiple of these Roblox
ones because your mind is Roblox. OMG,
memories of when I was like 15. Isn't
that 4 years ago? What the [__] You
were 15 4 years ago. Yo,
I'm old, 25. It's old. I'm ancient.
Okay.
Wow. Wow. This hole is for me? Yeah.
Wait, if you're in hunger, yo. Dude, I'm
sorry. I like can't make this even
remotely entertaining. Oh, that's
awesome. I played this on a loop for
hours as background noise. We have to
watch that together. What? With you in
my lap? My arms wrapped around you?
Okay, got you.
They literally just do
Yeah, and since you like it so much,
I'll allow you rub your crotch on my
leg. Haha. Oh my god.
This is
uh this is signal-less music like
signal-less beat. I love signal-less
music.
Your hunger 2 OST. I'm not putting my
soul into this. I can't do it. Can't do
it. Can't do it.
Degenerate DMs, no thank you.
No thank you.
Very disgusting people. Okay, now those
are the messages in order, I think.
Wait, but did I did I miss some? Hold
on. Hold on.
Did I I didn't miss some, did I? Oh, I
did miss some. What the Oh right, hold
on. I didn't do the ones from the next
day. Why? There are some from
There are some from September
that are out of order.
Okay, so then there's Food Shop sending
these pictures to the person. Now,
spoiler alert, this is not safe for
life. Not safe for life. Okay, we got
these pictures coming out. I'll try to
cover my eyes. I saw the first one. And
then we've got this picture as well.
Now, can somebody tell me, was this sent
censored or uncensored? What is Are
these censored added a
Go ahead.
Uh that was uncensored.
Okay, so
somebody else has censored this. Very
disgusting. I have censored this. Yes.
Gross. Gross. Gross.
>> Shop's OnlyFans?
Nope.
Did you know they had an OnlyFans?
I did a um I did a OnlyFans review
segment for Food Shop's. I've done two
OnlyFans reviews on YouTube. One for Bob
Blacks, one for Food Shop's.
Absolutely disgusting. True. True. So, I
sent you that documentary. That has a
bunch of clips uh that they've compiled.
Uh it basically shows Food Shop's lying
about being prescribed POCD, lying about
being prescribed by a therapist to jerk
off to lolly. So, they've lied at that.
Um
the Resi clips, his original stream is
gone. The only way to watch uh his call
with Food Shop's is through clips. The
best way to do that is probably through
a Queenman stream. And then Kilotonics
asks, "Who is better?"
Uh it's a tough race. It's a tough race
that I'd have to ponder. But if you gun
to my head, I have to answer right now,
honestly probably Food Shop's. Bob
Blacks is is really disgusting. So, it's
not that Food Shop's is better, it's
that one of them is is you know it looks
really bad, but
Wow. Absolutely horrific stuff, bro.
Absolutely horrific stuff.
True. Also, I don't know if um let me
know if the YouTube clip that I sent you
works. If not, I might have to clip it
myself and then send you like an MP4 or
something.
Oh, sure. Sure. Sure.
Yeah. Yeah. Give me a second. We're
still We're still looking around. Okay.
All right, I'm getting I'm getting a lot
of these links in. We're getting a lot
of these links in. Okay. Yeah, we
watched Thank you. Dickers sent me the
mister girl thing as well. Okay, we we
actually should probably keep watching
Food Shop's stream, her ranting about
Dan here. Okay. We should continue to
watch the the Dan ranting stuff because
we do want to mix this up. Okay, we want
to mix in some of the clips every once
in a while. He still doesn't Oh right,
right, right. That I was just going to
point out. Obviously, um there appears
to be some lolly Okay.
Oh wait, the tags are there.
Yuri
Okay, it doesn't say doesn't seem to say
lolly in the tags.
Sure, it looks like young kids in it,
but does not say I don't see lolly in
the tags, so hey.
Benefit of the doubt until
seen otherwise.
>> I think all of their concerns are
validated, okay? There's a reason why
Dan
>> Oh, uh
Oh, happy birthday to Dickers,
apparently. Dickers, is it your
birthday? Happy birthday, buddy.
Um yeah, happy birthday.
I think that all the DGGers who um
were fighting against Dan, I think all
of their concerns are validated, okay?
There's a reason why Dan was doing a
1v20, okay?
It isn't because Dan is the gigachad
that's like trying to do the 1v20
martial arts thing.
Fighting against 20 people? What was Dan
What was Dan fighting with people over?
What is she talking about here?
Was Dan fighting with like members of
Food Shop's
server to argue that she's a lollycon or
Oh, Dickers is old, eh? Damn, 33.
You look great for 33 though, okay? I'm
going to say it. I'll say it.
33, I wouldn't put you a day over 31.
You're looking great for 33. Okay.
What Does anybody Oh, the DGG Olympics.
Wait, was this Was this Hold on.
Give me a second.
Over the DGG Olympics. Okay, he was
arguing with people, but was it about
calling Food Shop's a Was it just over
the DGG Olympics in general? Something
to do with DGG.
I'm curious. thing, okay?
It's because Dan
is just wrong.
And everybody else is trying to point
out how wrong he is, but he just won't
back down, okay? That's literally it.
Okay? Sure.
Sometimes when you're getting dog piled,
you think that you're the right one,
okay? And sometimes when you're getting
dog piled, sometimes you're the
Okay, in this case, he's always the
right when he when he's getting dog
piled, okay? I'm just saying. So,
is the context
clear?
Is the context clear?
Now, here's the thing. Okay, Dan.
I think
that this is gay, okay? I think this is
gay and
Okay, you're looking well. Thank you,
Rex. Okay. I think this is gay and
I for one do not enjoy this, okay? I'm
only doing this because I view this as a
necessity because I know Dan's
character, okay? And honestly, if I
monetize this You know what? I'm all for
it. Do you know why? It's because I
think that if I have to suffer, I think
I should at least make money suffering,
okay? Because ain't no way you're going
to get me to suffer for free, okay?
Ain't no way you're going to get me to
suffer for free. There's no way you're
doing that to me, okay? So, you know
what? Very interesting.
>> Yeah, I am going to stream this, okay?
Now, with that being said,
with that being
I mean, I Listen, nothing Food Shop's
has said in this stream is anywhere near
as bad as her wishing like harm and and
validating the harm, saying Kiwi Farms
is totally justified in doxxing and
swatting Dan and his family.
That was crazy, okay? That's a totally
crazy thing to say. Nothing she said
this time has been anywhere near that
bad.
Although, I don't I don't know exactly
why she thought that was a good thing to
do, but
he said. Again, all right. All I'm
asking from Dan
is to not call me any child-related
crazy when I'm trying to defend your
friend, okay? I'm trying to defend your
friend Destiny, okay?
Dan, it's really inconvenient for you to
point point out all these child things
about me, okay? My child attractions.
Really inconvenient when I'm trying to
defend your friend from allegations of
>> [laughter]
>> You can't make it up, okay? Listen, I
can't defend your friend over his
allegations that he's hoarding if you
call me a
Okay, regardless of how true it is, I
cannot do that.
Please stop. Think of Think of what
you're doing.
Okay? Yes, I criticize you. Yes, I'm
very very harsh against you and your
character. But notice, before all of
this, I did not go after your family. I
did not go after your kids. I did not go
after your wife. I did not go after
Oh, wait. Is she lying? Is she just
lying?
Hold on.
Wait, from from the days before this, we
have those clips. What the hell? Wait,
where did those clips come from then?
Wait, is this like AI? Hold on. Do we
need to watch this again?
Good for him.
My boy.
Probably got arrested again.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Where was this?
Just remember every single battle I pick
is justified, okay?
Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Sorry, I skipped way too far forward.
>> Food Shop's is wrong. About what?
So, that's kind of expected.
Hey, why is Why is Dan here spinning
here? This is 2 days ago.
And that's why I criticize his
parenting, okay?
So, first she criticizes his parenting,
which I would say is not the same as
going after kids, okay? You stop there,
then it's not the same as going after
his kids. That's why I think it's a
reasonable escalation, okay? That's why
I think it's a reasonable escalation,
okay?
I hope that your wife gets harassed more
at work, okay? So, that of course is a
reference to Kiwi Farmers and not just
Kiwi Farmers, but Gato Fumador, okay?
The the H3 snark adjacent guy. Everybody
trying to dox Dan's wife, say call Dan's
wife at work, right? That's an insane
escalation. Dan's done nothing close to
that. Jesus.
Oh, is there still in here?
He's been He's been in here.
He's [__] mad.
So, Dan says pet should Food Shop's
Anyway, who cares? And Food Shop's says,
"Huh, it's really cool that Kiwi Farms
doxxed your wife and tried to call her
at work."
Amazing stuff. Good for him. My boy.
Probably got arrested again.
King.
Probably in some girl drama again. Okay.
I hear that's been happening. Yeah?
It's rare. All right, I'll speed it up.
Wait. Wait. Wait. We're speeding up.
Every single battle I pick is justified,
okay? Just want
Just in case anyone wonders if I'm being
unhinged. Uh-huh.
>> All right, well.
Love you guys and uh stay safe. Be
careful.
All right, see you then.
Jesus.
Uh no, by by the way, got to sting that
nobody gave a [__] about that comment.
There wasn't a single person there who
was like, "No, don't say that about Food
Chops. Food Chops isn't a pedo."
Notice that? Notice that how she defends
Destiny no matter what. He didn't say
[__]
Nobody else there wanted to go, "No,
Food Chops No way."
You can't call Food Chops a pedo. That's
crazy, dude.
There's no way you could call her that.
Get out of here, man. Didn't happen.
Okay, a little bit later in the stream.
Well, what can you do? Haters going to
hate, okay?
They hate us cuz they ain't us. True.
Wow.
Holy Very cool stuff.
Bro, he called me a pedo. Yeah, of
course I don't want to feel bad for him
anymore. Yeah, or for his wife, or for
his kids. What the Of course I hope they
get harassed more.
So, just to be clear, that's very
different, right? Those are very
different things. Going from I don't
care about him or his wife or whatever
to I hope they get harassed more. That's
very different, okay? Morning Take End,
how's it going?
But wait, but wait, if you thought
that's where it got bad, just wait.
There's more. There's more. Yeah. I hope
he I hope he gets stocks. I hope he gets
swatted. You know, I don't care anymore.
Wow.
That seems totally That seems like
totally fair for an offhanded comment
that nobody even felt the need to push
back on.
For you to go, "Oh yeah, every one of
those Kiwi Farmer tactics I've been
saying are evil and life destroying?
Yeah, we should do all of them to Dan
right now."
I thought
I thought I thought Dan was a victim. I
thought Destiny was a victim. What the
[__] man? All right.
Cool. Oh boy. Oh boy. She's about to
realize how quick reality flips, okay?
You go You have to go You go after
certain people in that community,
reality just goes upside down. All the
things you were arguing before and
everybody's like, "You're correct.
You're correct. You're correct." All
that's going to change.
That'll change real fast, all right?
>> You as a person, as an individual
character.
>> No, hold on. But notice before all of
this, I did not go after your family. I
did not go after your kids. I did not go
after your wife. I did not go after you
as a person, as an individual in the
sense of you being a creepy predator
person, okay? How
Okay, so maybe it's possible that they
mean before Not today, but before Dan
called them a pedo.
But then I I'm sorry, but you're just
saying, "Okay, I can just say I can do
whatever I want. I can advocate for you
being getting doxxed and swatted if you
call me a pedo."
I feel like the appropriate response,
okay?
You want to use the Destiny-ism,
the tit-for-tat in this situation would
be just calling him a pedo back.
In which case, I'm pretty sure he would
just go, "Oh yeah, turnabouts fair
play." Move on.
>> ever. However, the moment you take apart
that bar, it's just all-out war.
Yeah, no, it's it's got to hurt, Riles.
Got to hurt, okay? When
when he's when Destiny's sitting there
and he doesn't even notice that Dan just
called Food Chops a pedo. Doesn't care.
Right? Food Chops literally going
as hard as she can to defend Destiny.
Lying as much as she has to. Whatever
she can do, she'll do to defend Destiny
and Dan's like, "This person's a pedo."
And Destiny's just like, "Mhm."
Her, yeah.
Anything else, man?
>> or and it's nasty and it's bad for
everyone, okay?
But here's the thing, okay? You didn't
want to de-escalate and now we're here,
okay?
>> Yeah, Destiny is going to love this.
Destiny needed a convenient way to ditch
the pedo.
I I think he'll, you know, he'll do his
normal avoiding thing. He'll let it go
for a while. I don't think he'll ever
totally abandon Food Chops. He'll go on
Food Chops' stream and stuff. He'll make
it seem like he's supporting Food Chops,
okay?
Needs them to continue doing their work.
>> Adult decisions, adult consequences, all
right? Yes? Push, pull. You are in your
40s. You need to figure this out, okay?
You're like twice my age. Twice. You're
twice my age, bro. You're like 50% more
of my age or some [__] all right? No,
you're you're almost you're almost twice
my age.
There's no excuse for any of this
immaturity, okay?
There's just no excuse, all right?
Oh, there's no excuse for calling me a
pedo while There's no excuse for this
immaturity. Hold on. Ho- ho- hold on.
Wait, we need some uh we need some clips
here.
What do we got?
What do we got? We have this one. What
is this one?
>> partner?
I like femininity.
But do you like it more or less than
like masculinity? I want a cute little
girl that I can wrap my arms around. So,
you like being like in the dominant
role? Yes.
Okay.
Like a partner? Cool. Now, on on its
own, not damning, okay? On its own, not
damning. Weird, given some of the other
things.
Right? Cuz that makes it physical, that
makes it real, makes it in the real
world. But
hold on. I'm in I'm only into the most
feminine of the most feminine. That's
what I'm
Wait, what does that mean? I need to I
need to have a little girl to wrap
myself around. Oh, like you're like
big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get you.
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old. Just
in case you actually thought for a
second, "Oh, this is just like big
little stuff. That's totally normal."
What?
No. I'm in I'm I'm
No. No. No. No.
Oh boy.
All right, that's
woof.
Yikes. What do you want to call them a
pedo? Okay, that would be really If you
guys called
this person a pedo for some reason after
these comments, that would be really
inappropriate.
Okay? Really [__] inappropriate.
Wait, what is this? Oh, this is the
songs, right? Right, right. We had the
songs before.
We We can give this one one more listen.
If you believe that,
I'll wrap you.
You know why? Cuz Cuz I'm You goddamn
Right. I'm a literal
Now, of course, this could just be
satire, right? This could just be
satire. But I think with some of the
comments they've made, some of the
things they've said, we'll get to the
therapy discussions a little bit later.
I don't know if you can just discount
this stuff. It's like it's getting to
the point where it's like, "Oh, this is
very weird. You're like flirting with
this stuff in a way
Are Are you flirting with it? Is it
Oh boy. It's a legally valid confession
thinly hiding between the song cover.
I don't know about that, but man, I'm
I'm getting close to I'm just about
there, okay?
Really makes you think.
Yeah, I mean
Oh man.
That's some some yikesy stuff. I'm just
going to say it. It's some There's some
yikesy stuff going on here, okay?
Now,
okay, I've got I've got the next part,
but we should keep watching Food Chops,
all right? We We want to intersperse
some of these clips just just in case
they want to react, we should
intersperse some of the clips so they
have to dodge around the actual reason
somebody would call them a pedo.
>> how I No, you're almost twice my age.
There's no excuse for
You're almost twice my age. How dare you
see these clips and call me a pedo, Dan?
It's It's crazy. It's unhinged. That's
like saying Destiny's pretending to be
because he confessed to it multiple
times. It's unhinged.
>> any of this immaturity, okay?
There's just
Sorry, I For the sake of the DGGers who
might watch this via Food Chops' stream,
I should probably avoid mentioning
Destiny just so they don't have their
brains shut off.
Okay? I'll I'll avoid it for the rest of
the time just so you guys can actually
understand the example.
>> all right? You're
It's crazy how immature you are. Like
I'm actually flabbergasted. I'm like
I don't know. Like I think it's crazy to
me, okay? Like at the very least, I
don't know. I don't know how you let a
trans girl get more like mature than you
or some [__] like that, but that's
crazy, okay? Dog, you need to go through
puberty again. I'm just saying, all
right? Like maybe your balls haven't
dropped. Like
>> [laughter]
>> Like I'm just saying, okay?
>> drink a martini, shaken not stirred. Say
no, man.
Yo, thank you so much, my dude. Thank
you so much for the five. Australian,
thank you. Um but yeah.
Uh there you go. That's the drama.
That's the stupid [__] And I um and I'm
What? Is that it?
That's it.
Oh my goodness.
I'm I'm shocked. Has anybody been
talking about on Twitter or anything
like her basically saying she thinks Dan
deserves to be doxxed and swatted?
Is there anybody talking about that on
Twitter? Like I feel like most people
were just unaware of this.
Very strange things to say when
apparently that's like the most evil
thing that could happen. I mean, it's
not new. Hold on, it's new for someone
like Dan.
It's definitely new to say, "By the way,
maybe this person just doesn't
understand like concepts or what they're
saying." Like right? They clearly can't
attach like concept like I was going to
say conceptual things, but concepts in
their head. They can't attach them to
like words and express themselves very
well.
Which, you know, in some cases I'm
sympathetic. Pot calling the kettle
black, but in other in other cases,
okay? I always know the direction I'm
going in an abstract way. I just
sometimes have aphasia. I like lose
words. Okay, this person just doesn't
understand how to
like reason with abstract concepts at
all. So, I feel like when they say
something like, "Oh, Dan deserves to be
doxxed and swatted and his wife deserves
to be harassed." They don't connect that
to like the other arguments they've made
or anything else they've said in the
past. They just say something emotional
in the moment that they think sounds
vaguely Destiny-coded. And then they
they don't like ponder the consequences
of the things they say. They don't
ponder any of the implications of the
things they say. They just say them and
then they deal with it as it goes,
right? That's like their life. They
They're just tumbling through life as a
I don't know, like an input-output
machine. Like the All things they say
are just a function of like
give me the nearest approximation of
something Destiny would say.
You don't have aphasia. I I know I
don't. I just sometimes feel like I do.
I reach for words sometimes, okay? I
reach for words. From a 15-year-old.
What is this? We got one more We got
another
clip here. Hold on.
Have you ever heard of people sending
non-consensual or non-solicited vag
pics? What are you talking about? Okay,
clearly clearly I've never dealt with
crazy 15-year-olds before like I did,
okay?
>> You don't send pictures of a 15-year-old
I think that that one probably is out of
context, but we're going to laugh
anyway, okay? We're going to laugh
anyway. Very funny.
Funny stuff.
I'm just going to assume I'm just going
to assume that like Jstark is going to
Jstark is going to make a [__]
segment on me later because of Dan,
okay? So, I mean
No, not because of Dan, because of the
[__] you said about Dan that was totally
insane.
Yeah, do you think you could Do you
think you could say you want Dan doxxed
and swatted and I wouldn't cover it? Do
you think you could do that? That's
That's crazy That's like a total
detachment from reality.
I will I will say thank you to Food
Shops for She actually got away with it.
She got away with saying Dan and Dan's
family should be harassed by Kiwi Farms,
okay? Or at least that's the
implication. She got away with it. And
then she decided to keep pressing on it
until we looked into it and somebody
sent me the clips of her saying these
crazy things about his family on stream.
So, thank you Food Shops for not letting
it go, deciding to press down, and
helping me look into it. I really
appreciate it.
Yo, what was that? That was Spruce
Willis with a gifted sub. Thank you very
much, Spruce Willis. Appreciate it,
buddy. Thank you. This is not real. This
is a joke, almost certainly. Digger
says, "I spoke to her in private. She
confirmed that she did get sent pics
from a 15-year-old, but the 15-year-old
was trafficked, so she's innocent." That
is a joke. That is comparing it to the
Destiny situation. Listen, guys, you're
allowed to get pictures from a minor.
You're allowed to solicit
and retain that
so long as that minor is being
trafficked. That makes you okay. That
makes you innocent. It's all good, okay?
It's all good.
>> Good job engaging in anti-fan tactics, I
guess. Like good for you. I'm glad that
you can learn something out of this
entire drama. And
This is This is the only argument they
have to ever defend themselves. Oh,
these people are unhinged anti-fans.
Remember what Destiny said? Remember
what Destiny said about these people?
They're unhinged anti-fans. They're
totally unhinged. They're crazy.
These These unhinged anti-fans. Destiny
said so. Destiny's going to tell you
guys that Dan's an unhinged anti-fan,
for sure.
I don't think so. Oh, who knows though?
Who knows? Guy has not been acting
rationally lately.
Again, a
>> [laughter]
>> Food Shop threatens to doxx and says she
wants Dan doxxed and swatted. She hopes
Dan gets doxxed and swatted. Destiny
says he wants to doxx Wicked Supreme.
This This community is just a bunch of
doxxers. It really is.
They're trying to distance themselves.
The The people around Destiny are trying
to distance themselves from Food Shops,
but Destiny needs her and it's a
creating just the funniest dynamic in
the world. Don't we love to see it,
guys? I've I feel like we I love to see
it. I don't know about you guys.
Don't forget the Discord. Oh,
I can forget about it. Listen, the cops
are the ones who shouldn't forget about
it, okay? I can forget about it.
I don't have to talk about it that much.
I think it's cool that they dropped the
pretense that they ever actually cared
about doxxing. I mean, was the Was the
pretense even there to begin with?
Bad Empanada I mean, under their
worldview, under their their exact
standard, yes, Bad Empanada has done
nothing wrong under their exact
standard.